un train sillonne régions oubliées
d'afrique du sud à son bord
aucun voyageur mais quinze médecins et
infirmières les sud africains en avaient
fait louper pas un mélange de langues
photo et swan a pour dire bonne santé
dix ans après les débuts de la
démocratie le fait noté par est l'unique
chance d'être soigné pour les
populations les plus démunies
cette année sa route le conduire le ping
tonnes une ville de 72 mille habitants
dans le nord ouest du pays
malgré la fin de l'apartheid les
communautés blanches noires et métisses
ils vivent toujours cloisonné dans
l'école métis de morning glory
les enfants reçoivent souvent leur seul
repas de la journée le jour où le fait
ne paie pas arrive on compte sur eux
pour les porter la bonne nouvelle pour
les enfants j'aimerais prospectus
chameau parents explique tout sur le
vélo fait pas face à carrington y aura
des médecins il y aura des psychologues
ça juste parce que les gens considèrent
qu'il y ait ce beau les gens qui ont ce
même petit ami des corses et il ya des
gens qui peuvent leur donner des
conseils
iny pas où le monde l'arrogant et elle
reçoit demain pour vraiment pas cher
type man show d'élèves et richie
cunningham tu veux aller aussi pour mes
yeux mon frère m'a dit que lui des rêves
c'est donc
[Musique]
raymond à 14 ans il a déjà deux ans de
retard à l'école parce qu'il ne voit pas
bien
[Musique]
les seize wagons du train viennent
d'arriver du personnel local s'empresse
d'installer les soldats tentent un peu
plus loin les premiers soignants montent
à bord et découvrent leur chambre
afrikaner pour la plupart ils ont entre
20 et 26 ans débarqué des grandes
universités de johannesburg pretoria
urban et ses futurs au titien dentiste
ou infirmières sont bénévoles
ils vont vivre à bord du train pendant
deux semaines
[Musique]
bonjour moi je fais installer
liliane symbo a vu l'appareil de
poursuivre ses études d'infirmier
cytologie à londres à l'heure de la
démocratie
elle décide de revenir pour prendre les
commandes le secret est aussi là pour se
montrer non elle massicot logiquement si
vous savez que ces personnes c'est que
vous devez servir ont besoin de ça
l'exil soutiendront mediterra l'eau 6h30
par un matin d'hiver de mondialisation l
ouest ressources pour les aider à
expliquer vous facile pour les motos que
je rappelle aux missions plus de 200
patients vont arriver dans la journée
ils ont souvent marcher des kilomètres
ou payer un taxi brousse pour venir
parmi les premiers raymond qui s'est
rasé les cheveux pour l'occasion et son
frère robert qui a payé le bus la gare
de ping tonnes n'a jamais été aussi
pleines à l'accueil on organise les
files d'attentes
[Musique]
c'est aussi cette femme les yeux
liliane signaux se mêle à la foule l
orienter patients ceux qui sont perdus
ou ceux qui n'ont pas réussi à obtenir
des tickets
[Musique]
c'est ici pour se faire tester les yeux
les avoirs des lunettes
oui mais je vais d'abord qu'elle est là
où il ya le pagne blanc monfils et les
formulaires et vous revenez me voir
on nous a dit de venir ici
les vieux pour les dents bien dans la
clinique est pleine seulement vous aider
pour les yeux c'est pas tes yeux
fabien assié toile a de la chance il
obtient le ticket numéro 108 dans la
liste d'attenté pour robert c'est déjà
trop tard revenir demain matin ici les
consultations sont gratuites pour un
médicament ou pour une dent en paient
moins d'un euro et une paire de lunettes
ne coûte que 6 euros un wagon plus loin
les patients sont déjà trop nombreux
tous veulent voir le dentiste le docteur
maure in treating heures le médecin le
plus convoité du train cette ancienne
étudiante avait commencé à bord du fello
paie pas en tant que stagiaire
aujourd'hui employée permanente
elle a 15 étudiants sous sa
responsabilité
[Musique]
jallet pour qu'on avance plus vite
qu'une faust
brad et moi sinon bah termine à 9 heures
ce soir à 17 ans première visite chez le
dentiste pour un évident
elle veut se faire enlever deux dents
face avoir peur suis moi et artest
j'ai commencé à tirer bradley et
étudiants à pretoria
l'année prochaine il sera diplômé pour
l'heure il a besoin d' aide et ses
maureen une fois de plus ce qui est
sollicité de vous déranger je n'arrive
pas à lancer
elle n'en savent pas comment prendre
soin de la personne par exemple
c'était une grande expérience en faisant
ça tape à l'université quoique cassation
par semaine c'est bien l'expression des
temps aux fesses et aujourd'hui dans
certains cas liliane doit intervenir
pour trouver une dernière place excuse
moi
à franges et une grande faveur c'est ce
trait d'en savoir un peu demandées
moring c'est sa prestation comme les ont
jamais dans un fauteuil s'il te plaît
maureen et surtout quand on est occupé
mais je négocie liliane c'est que
beaucoup de ses patients n'ont jamais vu
un médecin de leur vie pendant plus de
40 ans d'apartheid
on leur a refusé l'accès au soin
aujourd'hui les listes d'attentes de
l'hôpital public sont trop longues
le coût d'une consultation et 200 rands
l'équivalent de 15 euros
trop cher et les médicaments sont trop
rares j'aimerais qu'il y ait encore plus
de monde et profiter du temps pour moi
et qu'elle n'est jamais assez bien sûr
toujours du monde qui est la vérité
c'est qu'en afrique le train arrive même
à sandra raymond a dû patienter la
journée entière mais peu importe à
upington il n'ya pas d'opticiens qui
puisse l'aider et il ne voit pas très
bien
c'est ça le problème
[Musique]
dany est mieux comme ça oui
est-ce que c'est toujours aussi vive que
tu dois toujours aussi bien et là c'est
toujours aussi clair avec ses montées il
a déjà payé très bien
ambriz makoko et l'assistant général du
train l'homme toujours prêt à rendre
service
un jour pour aider les opticiens a
débordé il est devenu le monsieur
lunettes il eût été loupé pas andris
vient dé banlieue de johannesburg il est
de la génération de ceux qui sont jamais
allés à l'école parce qu'ils étaient
noirs aujourd'hui à 44 ans il sait lire
les prescriptions et avec jusqu'à 60
paires de lunettes par jour c'est
seulement 10 minutes pour changer de
personnes on voit quand elle repart avec
ses l'unef et qu'elle est toute heureuse
je suis content d'être celui qui est
derrière tout ça j'ai l'impression
d'être une nouvelle vie commence pour
raymond dont le rêve secret de devenir
docteur un jour félicitations à vous
tous c'est loupé par une équipe
formidable patient lui sont
reconnaissants nous avons rencontré
aujourd'hui des gens qui vous soyez là
et que vous pensez ce qui valorise touch
ipad
ces cancers savait qu'il avait une
importante ne sont pas grand chose que
c'est la plus belle chose donnée
dans les quartiers les plus pauvres de
ping tonnes comme dans plus d'un tiers
des foyers du pays
il n'y a pas encore d'électricité lou
est enfin arrivé mais les maisons en
parpaings promise par la démocratie sud
africaine se font toujours attendre
[Musique]
les consultations sur le train sont
terminés seul maureen reste à bord comme
souvent elle est la dernière à finir sa
journée
je crois que je vais pouvoir dormir
maintenant en s'engageant à bord du
fello paie pas maureen a fait un choix
de vie parfois difficile il faut
accepter de travailler et vivre pendant
neuf mois dans un seul et même endroit
le train tout est la victime c'est la
quatrième des médias justaret dans sa
chambre au titre
cet agissement
alors voici ma chambre petit de bègles
ce n'est pas comme si la jsb respectifs
telle est ma meilleure amie
est-ce que vous raconte pas si j'ai
l'impression que parce qu'elle se
passerait la balle hors jeu derrière
et moi je resterai seulement ils sont
contraints de sa maladie est ce que je
suis en train de faire les choses mais
moi ce que je suis là que je me dis les
mecs en six ans et cela nous donne un
mois après mois je pourrais faire et
très chaud si j'en ai envie
c'est pas cité je me suis réveillé à 4
heures on vit tout seul à quatre heures
et demie je n'ai pas besoin de réveil
soit révélée être sûr que tout le monde
soit réveillé sinon si je me les pharmas
nous allons commencer il faut que je
fasse ce que je fais tous les jours
bonjour bonjour comment allez vous matin
c'est qu'il va y avoir aujourd'hui on
espère que je pense qu'il va y aura du
monde parce qu il y a deux qui doivent
arriver là mais la belle est premier
servi sinon vient de va plus vous
journée bien combien si j'ai déjà tout
tracé
j'ai réveillé des choses j'ai parlé aux
patients des étudiants en ce sens et
dans l'autre sens si tout allait bien
vérifier que toutes les voitures sont
bien là vérifiez l'uimm a visité les
écoles
s'ils ont bien tous le matériel ce matin
maureen par la rencontre des écoliers
avec elle des interprètes des étudiantes
est une infirmière pour prévenir la
contagion des maladies les plus
fréquentes dans les familles pour
apprendre aux enfants les principes
d'hygiène les plus élémentaires
sur tadmait bausch open doors mort lente
et drôme lot-et-garonne et donc ne nous
ont rien fait
[Applaudissements]
sur les dangers sur les machines sur les
dents et sur les jours suivants on va
regarder d'en être un pas d'accord
[Musique]
une 460 enfants ont été examinés en une
semaine dans les écoles de ping tonnes
beaucoup d'entre eux recevront une
lettre à donner à leurs parents pour
qu'ils puissent se faire soigner dans le
train
[Musique]
surtout beaucoup de soutiens pas trop ça
doit passer pas lâcher été flashé à tort
et ils se partagent la brosse à dents
ils se transmettent leur mire avec de
jeunes n'ont pas assez d'argent pour
acheter du bras ça dans la question si
j'achète une brosse à dents il chante je
suis un lion la luminosité est vraiment
trop mignon
tu as mal à suivre
c'est bon pour toi merci belgique s'est
vraiment lâché mais au moins on le fait
pour une bonne cause et quelle est la
suivante
depuis six mois
k
c'est l'offensive à gaza n'a marqué
mardi
il faut cultiver le coton tige comme ce
mardi hépatites et ne doivent pas mettre
au four en oreilles chat
ils doivent juste la nettoyer
délicatement sa trompe à l'intérieur
c'est vraiment des visites médicales
quand on examine les oreilles des
enfants on découvre des pierres et des
morceaux de papier toilette et d'autre
un set up in town comme dans le reste du
pays
le chômage dépasse les 30% et
l'espérance de vie est de 45 ans dans le
quartier noir de baballe et non la
tuberculose et le sida sont parmi les
premières causes de mortalité
comment
un jeune psychologue du fello fait pas
car il y rend visite à kristanna un
groupe de parole pour une quarantaine de
malades du sida qui se réunit toutes les
semaines je m'appelle patricia je fais
partie du tristana et boissons à ces
seuils du cices plus de 5 millions de
sud-africains sont contaminées par le
virus
chaque jour mille personnes en meurent
carey est là pour informer et soutenir
psychologiquement ces malades mais m2
peut les soigner les traitements coûtent
trop cher il n'y aurait pas de suivi
médical possible une fois le train est
reparti j'aimerais savoir pour mon bébé
est ce que les médicaments vous pouvoir
agir sur la maladie
[Musique]
l'association à peine le temps de donner
quelques conseils et le thé loupé pas
doit reprendre son chemin
en une semaine il aura soigné environ
1200 patients rasch et 700 dans
l'imprimé plus de 400 terre de lune le
train ne reviendra pas
vinton avant deux ans trop nombreux
sont les villes défavorisées qui le
réclament
[Musique]
je sais trop bien que les sud africains
ont besoin dans ce si je peux leur
apporter mais on a serré ces punaises
modeste je me dois de leur donner le
meilleur de moi même si je peux soutenir
les permanences de les étudiantes et
faire sentir à ces gens qu'il comble
pour quelqu'un
alors julien sont récompensés liliane
sino fidèle à son poste et aux quarante
mille patients qu'elle accueille chaque
année conduit l'équipe au nord du pays
vers des régions plus isolé encore
prochaine station 3 mas tour ici aussi
nombreux sont ceux qui attendaient ce
moment depuis longtemps et fait quatre
morts quand la nouvelle de l'arrivée du
train de l'espoir se répand
[Musique]